quatrième jour du procès en appel de
jean pierre murat à dijon il est rejugé
pour le meurtre de christelle mairi en
1986 un meurtre qu'il continue à nier
elle a besoin bonjour vous êtes en
direct avec nous du tribunal alors ce
matin les débats se sont concentrés sur
les autres pistes explorées pendant l'
enquête
oui alors à l'heure où je vous parle
c'est delphine la petite soeur de
cristal qui est en train de témoigner de
sa souffrance qui explique que c'est un
traumatisme qui a bouleversé toute sa
vie mais vous l'avez dit auparavant la
cour a examiné les autres pistes
explorées
pendant quatre des pistes qui ont mené à
des impasses par exemple celle de
jean-luc que l'oiseau à neuf et reçoit
aujourd'hui décédé il est suspecté
d'avoir envoyé des courriers anonymes où
il revendiquait le meurtre de a et
christelle avant d'être écarté autre
piste celle de david khayat un voisin
une connaissance de collèges de
christelle qui était amoureux transi qui
avait essayé d'avoir une explication
avec elle le jour du meurtre avant que
les enquêteurs ne découvre pile à
disposer d'un solide alibi alors l'après
midi va se poursuivre avec d'autres
auditions celle du frère de jean pierre
murat et de ses amis des témoignages
clés qui devraient permettre à la cour
d'en savoir un peu plus sur la
psychologie et les troubles de l'accusé
merci et les impôts c'est suivre
également sur internet